thank you so much for that Sofia so I
will give you my lightning talk and we
will immediately segue from that into a
part of the program special for you so I
wanted to give you an explanation for
why we couldn't play our closing notes
game typically the closing notes game
works as follows you get disconnected
somebody usually me writes the slides
and somebody else presents them and they
don't get to see them this is an
opportunity for us to make fun of the
people that we work closely with and
putting together an event so for example
I would have a slide saying hi my name
is Brendan I'm from capital one I
haven't seen these slides before I'm
presenting impromptu don't worry I'm a
pro i'm also very well rested this is a
joke because brendan is a very well
rested gentleman who likes to take
copious amounts of naps to make sure
that he's upbeat and ready to go and so
it's an opportunity for us to needle the
each other a little bit unfortunately I
couldn't do it because and I'll start
the story here I end up giving a lot of
talks I speak at all the PI data events
and I give a lot of talks as part of my
work and so when you give a lot of talks
you need a way to put talks together
very quickly one way I found to put the
other talks very quickly is to take
something that I've worked on something
that I put a lot of ideas into and then
to move that over and just kind of throw
together some slides but I don't like
PowerPoint I don't like keynote they're
very clumsy tools I don't like the
online slide viewers the Google slides
are all that stuff I think it's all
garbage I used to do it in the Jupiter
notebook but even that's a little bit
clumsy and i found a tool called sent
that allows you to create slides very
simple in a style that looks like and
this is my presentation from earlier
right here the style looks like this
where everything's kind of zoomed in
except it didn't have the features i
wanted so i wrote my own version of it
in python and i ended up spending two
hours adding a feature to my own version
adding an image feature and that was the
time i was supposed to spend putting the
other the closing notes and i think this
is a very common problem that we run
into we have a problem in front of us
where we need to solve something to
accomplish some task but we get
distracted by something that's kind of
interesting so i'll show you my little
tool my scent top py the original scent
it looks like this it's about a thousand
lines of c code it has fairly
minimal bindings to some X libraries pi
sent is as you might expect let's go
here much smaller it's only 250 lines of
Python code it's very very simple it has
a couple of neat features where I can
present you won't be able to see it on
your screen but I can present what's on
the screen but also what's on my screen
and I can view one slide ahead one slide
behind or arbitrary offsets I can change
colors I can add images it's a really
simple tool for putting together
presentations like and i'll show you my
presentation where you have all the
texts oom din you can do a little cool
stuff and it's you know very easy and
i'm able to use this to put together
presentations very very quickly which is
a benefit for me so that's a tool if
you're interested in you know being able
to put the other presentations in this
style easily please come see me the code
is in no shape to actually be shown to
anybody so it needs to be cleaned up a
little bit but with just a couple hours
of work maybe an hour to a work or
depending on what deadlines are coming
up however much time I can spend
avoiding the deadline worth of work I'm
sure we get up on github and get some of
you using it as well it's not meant to
be a world-changing tool just a really
small simple tool that you can use for a
very specific purpose now with that said
I want to segue into the next part of
our program and I said to stick around
after lightning talks for free or Riley
books one thing I want to tell you about
PI data and um focus numb focus is an
organization that's built around
community PI data is a conference that's
built around community unlike all the
other data science conferences out there
pi data has one very important
difference which is this is a
community-run event it's run by you one
of the things that I want to see more of
impact in future PI data events so I
want to make them as participatory as
possible I want as many people at the
event to be participating it that's why
I think lightning talks are so important
it's an opportunity for folks who didn't
have the time to put together a full
submission to give a small five-minute
talk that's why what I want to do at
this point is encourage all of you not
to give a lightning talk but to give
maybe a static electricity talk a 30 to
90 second talk up here in front of
everyone just line up and I just want
you to talk about three things that are
very important to us into our community
when you came to PI data DC what did you
learn when you came to PI data to see
what did you love when you came to PI
data to see what inspired you and what's
going to inspire you to help build a
community and wherever you are you don't
have to talk about all three of them you
can talk about any one of them but I
want to I want to build a little bit of
community build some positivity and in
exchange for that will give you a book
how does that sound come on up come on
up we have three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven books so come on
up tell us what you learn what you love
what inspired you why do you want to
build a community locally why do you
think I did is important why are you
thankful to capital one come on let's do
it I don't want a book I just want a
chance to speak with all of you as James
mentioned earlier I co-organized the PI
data Chicago meet up I also help with
the conference I'm so excited to see you
guys building a community here in DC I
was here for half a day and I got the
chance to engage with tons of amazing
and wonderful people and I want everyone
to know that this room and this space is
what makes innovation in open source
software possible so please keep doing
this and everybody here rocks hi my name
is Stephen Hill I am relatively new to
data science but I've been studying a
PhD you've done a lot of learning and I
really enjoyed learning and one thing I
coming here I learned how to use desk
i'm super excited to not have to you see
so much to speed up things now i can
just stay in python but also i was
something i really love about the Python
community is how welcoming it is and how
much you get to work together encourage
each other and so yeah great to be here
and keep it up
oh hi everyone I'm Joe Pete and I will
call her at Capital One so when I heard
Kaplan was sponsoring another event we
do have quite a few hair I was I was
skeptical at first cuz I've been to so
many events with the past couple of
that's because I didn't know PI data to
begin with much about it I did my
research and I think it's been really
watered the thing that I learned the
most I think some of the tutorials were
really great on the first day I'm
looking looking forward to going back
and trying a paralyzing work also there
was a great talk on specie some struggle
with NLT k for so long and most of my
questions always end up being around it
so yeah there are a couple of tools i'm
looking forward to implementing in my
work and no sir everybody should have n
PI data please hi my name is Anthony I
organize the data viz DC meetup group
with john gonzalez reported DC to data
community DC i want you guys to all come
out if you can it's a great meet up and
this has been a really good opportunity
to meet people in the python an
ecosystem our goal is to make data great
again we're going to make data great
again you know we learned so much about
parallel processing data mining data viz
data graphs and we're going to put the
data scientist back to work we're going
to make America great we're going to
make data grade hi my name is Gustavo
and the things that I really learned and
I'm very excited to go back and start
reading about them are dusk yellow brick
and graph tools and one thing they
really loved about the conference is
that I come from a non-traditional data
science background so my talks were a
little bit different and far we removed
from what you usually get but i love the
cure the cure
that people showed by going to my talks
and engaging on that and he just also
shows how welcoming the communities oh
okay hi everyone I learned quite a lot
at this conference it was a lot of fun
what I loved was just hot collaborative
everyone was to just share their
knowledge what they do and kind of
afterwards be also willing to talk in
detail further about things and actually
what inspired me was Sophia's talking to
ian I just love it when projects you
know come out and say hey we r mu you
know new people friendly you don't see
that a lot and sometimes when you're
trying to break into the open source
community it's a little difficult
intimidating so thank you for that yep
knows it hi all this is masha me and i
work for a consulting company the thing
that I really liked about this even
about the agenda it was very holistic so
it started from data preparation
dimensionality reduction model building
deployment security and the
visualization and telling the story so
the holistic agenda really attracted me
and definitely I love that ho the data
preparation because I think that is
extremely important no matter what model
you are building and the way i am going
to implement it and the way i'm going to
use this because this will help me to
better guide my clients on some of the
latest and greatest techniques that are
used in data science space so if nothing
else this would at least help them to it
you know to get better understanding
around what people are using and
definitely last but not the least the
whole mix of the audience from data
enthusiasts who have never used any data
science techniques to the people who are
really geek and professors so it has all
sorts of people from all sorts of
umbrella so that is really exciting so
thank
hi I'm Daniel Goodman with wgl energy I
was at the happy hour on Friday night
and I'm just talking to one of the guys
there any quotes developers developers
developers and I'm like oh you've
listened to that pop that podcast too
and it's just kind of like oh yeah these
are my people like you know I think we
all kind of get siloed in our worlds and
we forget like there are other people
out there that are really excited about
data analysis and data signs and you
know we have this wonderful event that
we can all come together and connect and
I'm really excited about that I also
hadn't heard about Luigi until this
weekend and we just you know for a lot
of things just kind of wait for things
to break and then go in and fix it and
then restart from the beginning and
finding out that there's something that
actually can manage a set of processes
and make sure they all complete makes my
life a whole lot easier so something to
look into well 40 years ago I began my
career in the weather service
programming and Fortran and we had these
big binders of subroutines and we would
take them if nobody else did we would
take these and type them in and on punch
cards and I thought Jesus is great
there's a pretty soon there'll be a
subroutine for everything available well
it never really did happen in Fortran
but I now that I'm retired I see that
it's happening in the Python community
in the open source in general so I
decided to talk to dive into this and
I'd like to thank you all for the
efforts that you put onto to make your
hard work available for others
hi my name is Sonya and I'm a recent
graduate student and so I'm still
learning a lot about data science and
there was a lot of good talks and I
learned a lot about just cool tips and
tricks of pandas Python a few a few
talks I liked was the clustering talk
the Python users talk thanks Daniel
about the resetting the index I had no
idea and pipelines I have to learn more
about that and use it uh yeah it was
great and I recently went back so it's
great to see that there's a good data
science community in DC so thank you hi
I'm Jackie castle so I learned two
things at this conference I've learned
lots of things but two things I wanted
to highlight one it's really really hard
to get people to share links to their
slides so please tweet them at me if you
haven't if not I'm going to be tracking
you down one by one and if you have a
twitter account possibly publicly
shaming you and i also learned how well
the num focus foundation puts together a
conference I've done I sit on the board
of the Python Software Foundation and
I'm one of the organizers for pike on
and I've helped out with scifi and I
just felt like like I didn't have to do
as much work so that was really really
nice so I just wanted to give a shout
out to that love love love the community
there's also a run women data science DC
and there was a couple of groups that
actually want to mirror it in other
cities so we might do like a growth
thing and the people inspired me thank
you
hi my name is kenisha first I'd like to
thank women data scientist DC for
sponsor me to come to this event because
otherwise I would have been stuck
watching the videos on YouTube about a
week from now when they post them so
thank you what I learned at this
conference was that I have a lot more to
learn I was at the beginning of my data
science learning journey so there's a
lot more to go but I'm not as lost as I
thought I'd be and so that's one of the
biggest takeaways I've had from this
conference the second thing that I loved
is just how everybody uses data science
there's so many different ways to use it
and so kind of seeing the options that I
have once I moved forward in my data
science journey I think that was really
cool as well and then what inspired me
was a Renee's talk this afternoon I'm
just the kick in the butt to remind me
that I shouldn't get discouraged along
this journey um you know seeing all
these amazing people here and what they
know I'm like I don't know anything at
all but it's just one day I'll get there
too and so that was kind of good to be
reminded of thank you hey my name is min
I work as the data scientist first
thoughts a small start-up and I thought
it was pretty decent at Python and I
came here and it was a very humbling
experience the coolest part here is that
actually volunteer at data kind and I
was think about doing some NLP stuff and
then I realized I'm don't know anything
about LLP and I want to like learn upon
it so these modern LP technique that was
done on friday with spacey nitk and
we're tyvek were really useful because i
will be definitely be stealing all that
code and you know refitting from my
purposes and I think if anyone wants to
get involved with data kind I am running
a project with the Consumer Product
Safety Commission I'm really chill we're
really chill so I'll come talk to me and
thanks
I'm Brian I learned many applications of
how it's being used in the field and I
love to learn that there's a community I
kind of felt like a little bit alone and
I feel that that has inspired me that to
try to contribute more to the open
source community so yeah hi good
afternoon I'm mark vice minh i'm one of
the founders of data community DC so
we've had a few folks here representing
some of our different programs I just
want to say that this has been a great
event and for those that don't know you
know we have had data community seed
running different kinds of events mostly
opens around data science and open
source for the last couple of years so
working with the PI data folks and this
conference you know I sort of see the
really the community coming together so
I really encourage you to check out the
broader community as well and also you
know having been sort of part of the
open source community for a while I'm a
big our user and yes I'm in a Python
conference but when i started the meetup
group i didn't know our and i learn our
by running the meetup group itself so
trust me there's a lot to be learned by
this community and for me it's been an
inspiration so thanks for the pie do
team pay to DC team and for capital one
and none focus and anaconda like
everyone who's made this possible and I
really really you know we really have
built a vibrant community here in the DC
area which which were really proud of so
please check out our events come join us
come talk come participate and
contribute so thank you
everyone the last folks who have been
here it's it's dwindled the numbers are
dwindled here on a Sunday afternoon
thanks for sticking around I've learned
that there's an amazing community here
in DC that's it's wonderful is the 23rd
PI data now James tells me which is
amazing achievement and it happens
because of individuals like you who make
it happen I learned I learned that the
choice to make PI data community event
was the right one when we started back
in 2012 and created the first PI data
and then created an unfocused and talked
about how do we do this right you know
how do we actually create community and
there's such an energy here and such a
momentum and such an opportunity but how
do you help it along it is really
important I want to sort of again learn
the importance of foundations and an
anchor points right there are people who
spend all their time working on this
damn day in and day out it's important
so funding is important and learn the
importance of funding these sorts of
things it's really important to have the
volunteers to make sure it moves and all
that comes together but it's also really
important to have an anchor of funding
so as you go back to your lives
organizations your communities recognize
that numb focus needs support non focus
needs donations them focus needs people
who are funding it so there's lots of
ways that can happen by a donation from
your company via individual donation to
the projects there's lots of ways that
can happen but it is important that's
how this sustains and maintains its one
of the mechanisms of staying open source
another mechanism to come out spend your
weekend geeking out with a bunch of
friends in the in a data community and
building momentum around the things you
do perfect I love seeing all the new
people here I love seeing all the kinds
of things people are doing with the code
other there's some people here at the
Euler number so if you notice nobody
David talked on number at PI data we
gave a bunch of it first it's still
moving along it's an amazing product
we've actually you can compile your
Python code fastest Fortran I heard a
guy from Fortran you can write Python
code for loops nested for loops and it
runs as fast as Fortran then you put on
a GPU make it be running faster than
your CPU Fortran so I learned that
there's some folks here need to learn
numba go check out go check it out try
it out thanks that's it
thank all of you here for helping make
this event such a success let's give one
final round of applause to our sponsors
capital one anaconda h2o y hat the
Python Software Foundation women in data
science DC the center for open science
and cloud Academy for making this event
so fantastic that's all we have planned
for you if you want to be a part of the
PI data community here in DC find me
find Andy finally find Savannah right
now will help connect you there's a PI
data event I think there's a PI data
meetup group already in DC so if you
want to continue this level of energy
find us fine Brendan we'll make it
happen let's let's see if we can make PI
data DC 2017 happen as well that's it